I would think there might be
disadvantages to not being able to hear
if you're riding a motorcycle
professionally needing to hear the the
shifting of the engine here other racers
coming up on either side of you I mean I
would think it would be a disadvantage
yeah for sure it's it's a little
disadvantage you know I can't hear I'm
obviously so I have to hold my line I
can't move around on the track I'll hit
them
it's a advantage off the track cuz I
can't hear them talking trash about me
or anything
[Applause]
you are 5 feet 2 inches tall do you is
that a problem when you're riding these
bikes are very powerful these bikes are
very fast and they're big machines is
that a disadvantage in the sport yeah it
definitely is a disadvantage you know
I'm only 5 - of course I weigh a hundred
pounds I ride a motorcycle that's 200
pounds so you know trying to hold the
bike when it's really on a rough track
it gets difficult so but it's an
advantage on the start because I'm so
like that I can get out front so that
really helps me okay you you now you
race women exclusively but you're
interested you would like to race guys
is that true yeah for sure I always
wanted to race with men I grew up racing
boys and I think I can do it
win-win I know you can
when you were younger you had pink hair
and you still have something kipper you
had bright pink hair and you liked it
when you raced against boys you liked
having pink hair y-yeah of course I've
always loved pink hair since I've been
little and you know I wanted my first
national with pink hair and I always
thought it was good luck for me and you
know it doesn't hurt when you pass a boy
with pink hair they know they've been
passed yeah you were not unconscious in
a crash before the 2011 X Games and you
could not compete what does that do to
your attitude this year does it make you
is it give you more fear or in a way
does it make you more determined
no I'm definitely more motivated this
year I'm gonna come back and I'm gonna
be ready to win a gold medal my third
one and I'm ready yeah this is I'm gonna
do my best that's all I can really do
[Applause]
Jim do you you grew up racing you race
for a long time your dad raced for a
long time do you are you comfortable
watching Ashley race now as a young
woman or is it difficult for you to
watch is it scary yeah I mean I grew up
doing it my dad
I've watched Ashley do it but no it's
not something that you ever get
comfortable with you know it's something
that I mean that's my kid I love my kid
I want her to be safe so you know I get
nervous just like anybody else and I
want the best for but actually when the
gate drops I like don't get them you
know so that's the the fear goes away
and you know but of course you know I'm
always concerned with her I never get
comfortable with that yeah all right
well absolute joy having you on the show
thank you so much for being here yeah
you